some breaking news this afternoon the
White House has confirmed that Hamza bin
Laden that's the son of a sama bin Laden
has been killed in a US counterterrorism
operation a White House statement said
that the loss of Hamza bin Laden not
only deprives our kinda of important
leadership skills and the symbolic
connection to his father but undermines
important operational activities of the
group when our foreign affairs editor
Deborah Haynes is on the line for us
Debra as in so far as the war on terror
goes this news is a pretty huge
development well it's it's a development
but I wouldn't say is a huge development
because we have known for the last two
months that Hamza bin Laden was
suspected to have been killed that NBC
actually broke that line back in July
and while there was no official
confirmation or official public
statement from the White House sources
off the record were indicating that that
was what was believed also the timing of
the death that hasn't yet been confirmed
it's understood that it happened in the
first two years of the presidency so
that would be kind of 2017 2018 so this
isn't a recent development but very
interestingly and importantly al Qaeda
itself has yet to actually comment on
this confirm or deny that Hamza bin
Laden is dead the fact that you've got
Donald Trump the White House saying that
that he is dead and he was killed in a
US counterterrorism operation in the
afghanistan-pakistan region that that
indicates that they must have solid
evidence to believe that it's true but
they're silent on the part of al Qaeda
is notable in terms of the actual impact
of what this means and his death
operationally actually it means very
little hamza bin Laden was being groomed
to be a of the al Qaeda group taking on
that role that began with his father
Osama bin Laden but that wasn't going to
happen anytime soon and well the
statement from the White House says that
he was
and playing a part in planning and
dealing with various terrorist terrorist
groups there's there's no real sense
that his death is actually going to
impact on operations and it's important
to remember that while al-qaeda has
perhaps slipped from the public minds in
the sense that Islamic state is the
group the terrorist group and the
Islamist extremist group that most
people think about when they think of
terrorist atrocities and attacks because
that has been predominant over the past
few years al-qaeda is very much still
they're still alive still planning still
seeking to conduct what's known as
spectacular attacks against the West so
well
yes it's important for the White House
to have hunted down and killed what they
believed to be the threat that was posed
by Hamza bin Laden the overall mission
of hunting down members of that group
continues yeah as you were intimating
there I mean the influence of al Qaeda
was considered to have been hugely
weakened wasn't it back in 2011 when
Osama bin Laden was killed but there's a
lot of talk in the last few months about
about the extent to which they have
rebuilt and regrouped yes and in fact I
interviewed Ben Wallace who was at that
time and the security minister over in
the summer now of course the defense
secretary and we were talking more
broadly about Islamist terrorism and and
misshape it it takes at the moment and
he made the point of saying that al
Qaeda is very much still looking to to
launch attacks including here in Europe
so clearly on the minds of of government
ministers of the security services and
yes while back in 2011 you had that the
SEAL Team six the US Navy SEALs
conducting that board ASUS raid into
Pakistan where they had found Osama bin
Laden's hiding place in the place called
a batterer bird and conducting that raid
in which the al Qaeda leader was killed
and that was obviously hugely important
for the u.s. give
the September 11 attacks back in 2001
that at that moment then there was a
huge huge blow to the group in terms of
the loss of such a charismatic leader
that had inspired so many and his
successor is a man called Ayman Zawahiri
he has he has much less of the same kind
of draw power that bin Laden Osama bin
Laden had and and you've seen over the
past few years with the spread and the
growth of Islamic state in in Syria they
were able to attract a lot more recruits
during that time because of their
ability to and to send out messages to
deliver messages across the internet
using social media using those slick
videos to try to spread their propaganda
which unfortunately was successful and
that something that al-qaeda hadn't done
in the past as effectively but obviously
it's a learning organization and it's
really important to remember that it
hasn't gone away